[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: So thank
you, Fred, for coming along.
Many of you will know--
in fact probably all
of you know quite a lot
about Fred, at least
from his public persona, if not
his blog, then his amazing work
in venture capital
here in New York.
So Fred was a--
correct me if I get
any of this wrong-- a graduate
of MIT in engineering,
then also a graduate of the
Wharton School of Business
in UPenn and then
pretty early on was
a venture capitalist in New
York City at Euclid Ventures.
Then he founded his own
fund, the Flatiron Ventures?
FRED WILSON: Partners.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Partners.
I'm sorry.
FRED WILSON: It's OK.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: And then
in sort of the classic New York
City move, his next big step
was moving like nine blocks
downtown, Union Square Ventures,
which is the one, I think,
we are all probably more
familiar with that funded
companies like Twitter
and Tumblr and Foursquare
and Delicious and a whole
bunch of other companies that--
FRED WILSON: No one pulls
that one out anymore.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Well,
we know Josh Schachter.
We, in fact, tried to
hire Josh Schachter here.
So it's sort of a
bittersweet thing.
FRED WILSON: Don't you
know he's unhireable?
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: He
did eventually join Google.
But then, did you see he's
building these robots,
the whiteboard robots?
FRED WILSON: He's great.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
So I'm not going
to go into much
more description,
except to say that Fred is
one of the very few people, I
think, who have made a
significant individual
contribution to the
technology ecosystem
here in New York City.
I think when people
around the world
think of tech in New York
City, they think of Fred
as somebody who's enabled that
and encouraged that and pushed
that forward and, furthermore,
is the voice of that.
And so we're going to talk a
little bit about that, I think,
today, but also about
one of Fred's passions,
which is also a passion,
I think, of a lot of us
here, which is computer
science education, which
is in a fairly terrible
state and is really
standing in the way of
progress of the tech community
and the community in general
here in New York and elsewhere.
But with that, welcome, Fred.
Thank you for coming.
FRED WILSON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: So
I'm kind of interested,
first off-- you were kind
of in venture capital early,
it seems like.
FRED WILSON: Yeah.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: How
did you fall into that?
Was that focused?
Is that something happened onto?
FRED WILSON: It really
came out of the decision
that my wife and I made to move
to New York in the early '80s.
And I had been at MIT
and was an engineer.
I didn't major in
computer science.
But I put myself through
MIT by writing software
and then got a job here in
New York writing software,
but not for a start-up.
And all my friends from MIT were
working in Cambridge at places
like Lotus-- now I'm dating
myself, because this is 1983--
or moving out to Silicon Valley
and working for PC software
companies, or even PC
hardware companies,
which was the thing of the day.
And I wanted to do that.
But I was living in New York.
And my wife was really
committed to staying here.
And so I started trying
to think about how I
could stitch that all together.
And New York still
is, and certainly
was at the time, the finance
capital of the world.
And so I kind of
landed on this idea
that I could marry finance
with technology and start-ups.
And then I discovered
there was this thing called
venture capital, which I
honestly never heard of before.
I did a bunch of
research on that.
And then I tried to get a job.
And everybody said
you had to get an MBA.
So then I went and got an MBA.
I wrote my application
to business school
saying I wanted to be
a venture capitalist.
And I managed to get a job.
MBA is usually a
two-year program.
I got a job the summer
between my two years
working in a venture
capital firm in New York.
And I've basically been doing
venture capital ever since.
That was in 1986.
So I've been doing it
for close to 30 years.
And you're right, I basically
didn't know anything
when I got into the
venture business.
I knew how to write software.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Right, right.
FRED WILSON: But back then,
that was less of a thing.
Now, we won't hire somebody
if they can't write software.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Sure.
Well, fortunately, it's a
little more common than it was.
But it needs to be more
common yet by, I don't know,
maybe an order of
magnitude, I don't know.
FRED WILSON: Well, we have
this one young analyst
who works for us.
And yesterday, he was talking
about this open source
messenger called Telegraph.
And his way of doing
research on Telegraph
was to build a bot for Telegraph
on the new, launched-last-week
bot platform.
And that makes so
much sense, right?
If you want to figure something
out, make something with it.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Keep poking at it, yeah.
FRED WILSON: And so
I think that's why
it's so important in my business
to have those kinds of skills.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Right, right.
So how have you seen,
since the last, what
are we talking about,
20-plus years--
what have you noticed happening
in the New York tech scene?
What do you think of the
trends and where we're going?
FRED WILSON: It's night and day.
I mean, it really
is night and day.
If you go back 20
years to the mid '90s
when we started
Flatiron Partners,
I don't think there was more
than one or two venture capital
firms that had real
focus in New York.
And most technologists
would not choose
to graduate from Carnegie
Mellon or MIT or anywhere
and come to New York
and make a career here.
The companies that did exist
were very vertically focused.
So they were companies
that served Wall Street
or served the publishing
industry, which is
a horrible way to make money.
And there weren't
that many of them.
And I think today,
everybody knows
that if you want to
be an entrepreneur
or you want to be a software
engineer in a start-up,
that you can do
that in New York.
And that one thing, to me, is
probably 80% of what's changed.
It doesn't mean that people
don't start amazing companies
in other places.
And it will always be the
case that New York will only
be a part of the tech sector.
But it's a meaningful
part of the tech sector.
In the United
States, it's probably
the second most active start-up
hub after Silicon Valley.
And that's a big deal, I think.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Yeah.
So what is it about
New York that-- you
mentioned your wife
really wanted to be here.
And you decided to
focus on New York.
Even apart from
technology, what is it?
And this is kind of a
self-congratulatory question
for all of us who have
chosen to be in New York.
But what is it that makes
you want to live here?
FRED WILSON: Well, I
think it's everything else
that you can have
outside your work life.
I talked to a venture
capitalist based
in Silicon Valley quite
a few years ago now,
maybe five, seven years ago.
And he said, you know, the
reason I like investing
in companies in Silicon Valley
is that there's nothing else
to do.
So the engineers will work till
2:00 or 3:00 in the morning.
And he said, you
know, in New York,
they all leave the office
by like 9:00 or 10:00
and then go out for beers with
their friends or something.
And I said, that's why
I live in New York.
I want that.
I want to be able
to do other things.
And I also think that
besides the lifestyle issues,
the other thing that, to me,
is so amazing about New York is
that if you're-- well, let's say
you have kids and you're going
to a soccer game on the weekends
and you're on the sideline
cheering on your kids.
Next to you will be
somebody who's a writer.
And then on the
other side of you
will be somebody who
owns a restaurant.
And there will be somebody
who works in government.
And then there will be somebody
who works on Wall Street.
This is very--
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
I think there's
a cartoon about this,
where in the Valley,
there's the tech lawyer and
the tech writer and the tech
restaurateur.
FRED WILSON: No, you go on the
soccer field in Silicon Valley,
you have people who
work at Google, people
who work at Facebook,
people who work on Sand Hill
Road in the venture business.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: And
they're not bad people.
FRED WILSON: No, I'm not
making a negative comment here.
It's just that there's
diversity of culture in work,
in life that you get
in New York that I
think is really positive.
And I think, by the
way, that does feed
into the start-up
ecosystem, as well.
I think there was an
article-- I don't remember
the exact number-- but something
like 40% of the companies that
are started in New York are
started by female founders.
Or maybe it was 40% of
the employees are female,
or something like that.
That's because a lot
of these companies
are e-commerce-focused, or
a lot of these companies
are media-focused or
focused on problems
that women are
more interested in.
And I think that
because of the diversity
of the kinds of companies
that get created here,
you see a diversity
of employee base
that maps pretty well to that.
And so that's what I think
New York has going for it.
It's no more
expensive to live here
than it is to live
in Silicon Valley.
That's not to say it's-- I mean,
it's ridiculous to live in New
York.
That's our biggest
problem, I think, probably.
The one thing that we
have here in New York,
though, that I think does
mitigate a little bit
about that is that we
have the outer boroughs.
So as Brooklyn gentrifies
and as Queens gentrifies
and as the Bronx
gentrifies, there
are neighborhoods in those
boroughs with good mass transit
where you can live.
And I think Silicon
Valley struggles
from that because of its
topography with the Bay
and kind of constrained spaces.
I think that New York,
even as expensive as it is,
it's a little bit more livable.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Yeah.
And we have lots of people
who commute in from out in New
Jersey, for example.
The hub-and-spoke
model of Manhattan
works incredibly well,
whereas in Silicon Valley,
there's almost no hub.
It's all spread out.
FRED WILSON: But we
have mass transit.
As horrible as
New Jersey Transit
is and Metro North is and
Long Island Railroad is
and the New York City subway
system is, we have it.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Right, right.
Correct.
Exactly.
FRED WILSON: And we take
it for granted, I suppose.
It's nothing for me to think
about hopping on the subway
and going out to Citi Field.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Right.
FRED WILSON: Right?
But that's kind of amazing
that you could do that.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Yeah, I agree.
So what's standing in the way of
the tech ecosystem in New York?
What do you think needs to
be fixed in order for us
to get to-- I don't
know if we ever
get to par with Silicon Valley.
That's also an
interesting question,
whether we need to get there.
But what are the big
bottlenecks right now?
FRED WILSON: I think
talent, to my mind,
is the number one thing.
Every one of our companies
has a voracious appetite
for, particularly,
engineering talent,
but also design talent,
product management talent.
I think New York
particularly suffers
from a dearth of really strong
product management talent.
That may not be
true here at Google.
But I find that when our
portfolio companies look
for product management
talent, they
oftentimes go hunting
in Silicon Valley
and try to relocate people here.
In Silicon Valley, there was
the enterprise software industry
and the personal
computer industry
and some other industries
that taught people
how to be really good
product managers.
And that discipline of
being a product manager
maps pretty well as you move
from software to web to mobile.
And in New York, we can do
that with marketing people,
we can do that with
financial people.
But we didn't really have this
base of product management
talent.
So I think that's one
area that's particularly
challenging here in New York.
But in general, these
technical skills-- and I
do consider them
technical skills,
and I don't mean that
in a negative way--
but you have to
actually really be
good at this stuff, whether it's
design or software engineering
or product management, and
really, really know your stuff
to make good products.
And we still have
too little of that.
And so everything
we can do to make
New York a magnet for
people to relocate here
or to create our own
organic pool of talent
is really important.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Right, right.
So drilling in maybe a
little bit to your portfolio
companies, or maybe
more generally,
to companies founded
in New York City,
what do you see
as big successes?
And how do we create
even more successes
without having too many
Googlers leave and start them?
FRED WILSON: Well, the
companies that we've
been involved with here
in New York who I think
have gone on to build the
most solid and sustainable
businesses that are still
independent would be probably
Etsy, MongoDB, Kickstarter.
I'm going to leave
somebody out, which
I'm going to feel
really badly about.
Even companies like
Meetup.com and Stack
Overflow or Stack Exchange
would be in that category.
People would point to
companies like Tumblr.
But Tumblr got sold.
So is it a great company?
Maybe.
But it's not an independent
company anymore.
So harder to really
point to that one.
And I think in many of
these cases, one of the keys
was that these companies had
business models from day one.
Etsy had a business model
the day they launched.
Kickstarter had a business
model the day they launched.
MongoDB had the open
source business model.
Meetup moved to a paid model
relatively early in their life.
Stack figured out how
to marry a careers
business with their platform.
So I'm a big fan of, if
you're starting a business,
you're in business.
And you need to
build a business.
And you can't just keep
making software and hoping
that revenue shows
up at your door.
So that, I think, is maybe
the number one characteristic
I would point to that has
made these companies be
able to do what they do.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Right.
So you mentioned the
talent problem with respect
to product managers.
And you were pretty
interested, in general,
in, how do we create more
computer science engineering
talent within New York?
So tell us a little bit about
how you came to that as a focus
for not just your
sort of business mind,
but also your
philanthropic endeavors
and what you're
working on there.
FRED WILSON: Well,
for me, it started
with-- my big breakthrough
in my own professional life
was learning how to write code.
And that opened up
opportunities for me that
allowed me to put
myself through MIT,
myself through Wharton,
allowed me to get my
first job out of school,
and even, frankly, got me into
the venture capital business.
Because the first
venture firm that
hired me was attracted
to that skill,
even though they didn't
expect me to write code.
But they thought because
I knew how to write code,
I would be able to help them
invest in software companies.
And so I guess I sort of feel
like this is something that
was a life changer for
me and probably was
a life changer for a lot
of people in this room.
And also, just
looking at the trends,
it seems like it's going to
be more important than ever
going forward.
And so if I'm
going to give back,
I want to give back to
something that matters to me,
that made a difference for me.
And I want to try to make that
available to as many people as
possible.
So that's where it comes from.
There is also, frankly,
a self-interested piece
of it, which is, hey, if
we have more organic talent
pool to pick from, then we can
help staff the companies that
get created here in New York.
And that actually came from
a couple of Google engineers.
I wrote a blog post about-- this
is now going back at least six
or seven years ago-- about my
growing interest in computer
science K through 12 education.
And a couple of
engineers here at Google
left comments on my
blog and said, hey,
there's this guy named
Mike Zamansky who
basically runs a computer
science program at Stuyvesant
High School.
You should go see him.
And I did go see him.
And Mike's been a
friend and an adviser.
We don't always
agree on everything.
But it's hard to agree
with Mike on everything.
And that was an early
introduction to the New York
City public school system.
And what Mike has created at
Stuyvesant is unbelievable.
I mean, literally, the kids
that come out of that program
go on to the best
computer science
programs in the country.
And many of them
do come back here
because their families are
here and they grew up here
and they can now get good
jobs here, maybe right here
at Google.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Is
there anybody in the room
who went through Stuyvesant?
FRED WILSON: We've got one.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
There's one.
All right.
There are a bunch around.
FRED WILSON: And so that was
like an a-ha moment for me.
I'm like, yeah, we
need more of this.
And then I got to the
social justice piece of it
from there, which was that there
are whole swaths of the New
York City public school system
where the kids never ever get
close to computer science.
And by the way, it's assumed
that they can't learn it.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Right.
FRED WILSON: And
that's the piece of it
that really kind of bugs me.
Because I think that if
you have the motivation
and the curiosity and the
tenacity to grind through it,
you don't need to be an
amazing mathematician.
There are certain realms
of computer science
where I think that's true.
But it's certainly not true
for all computer science.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
I think most of us
spend our days
adding 1 to numbers.
That's the extent of the
deep math that we do.
FRED WILSON: But
there are people--
CRAIG NEVILL MANNING:
And I think I agree,
there are exceptions.
But mostly--
FRED WILSON: There
are people who
believe that if you're not a
top achiever, if you're not
a rocket scientist, if
you're not a math genius,
you can't learn this stuff.
And I just don't
think that's true.
And so that's the piece
that maybe really reeled me
in at the end of the day
in a most material way,
is to see kids who
really don't have
strong academic credentials,
but are really curious about,
how do I make a program
on my smartphone?
And you teach them how to do it.
And they just, boom, the
world lights up for them.
And all of a sudden-- someone
called it super powers.
Like, I have super powers now.
I can do this thing that
most people can't do.
And it gets kids motivated
to come to school.
It gets kids motivated
to think about,
what am I going to do when
I graduate from high school?
Am I going to go to college?
Am I going to get a job?
All of a sudden, they
start seeing opportunities.
And they're excited about life.
Now, there's other things
that can do that for them.
It's not just computer science.
If you fell in love with design,
that could do it for you.
Or if you fell in love with
music, it could do it for you.
But it lights up something
for people in themselves.
And so that's the thing that
really got me completely,
totally into it.
And I am completely,
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Yeah, that's great.
So given that you're an
expert on, basically,
the various opportunities within
New York City to get involved,
I wondered if you could give
us a brief tutorial on what
the various options are
and what their aims are.
Because one thing I have a
problem with is, oh, wow,
there's a new
initiative that I could
get involved in teaching
kids at this time of the day
or this time of the year.
Could you sort of
map it out for us?
What are the interesting
things going on
that people should
be thinking about?
FRED WILSON: Well, the two
probably most well known
programs that have a
volunteer component to them
are the ScriptEd program,
which was mentioned
by-- I forget his name now--
the guy who opened things up.
It started out as an
after-school program
and now has an
in-school program.
And the cool thing
about ScriptEd
is it teaches kids
software engineering.
And then the best performers
get the opportunity
to go into summer
internships that they also
help place them in.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Wow.
FRED WILSON: So it's not
just an education piece,
but there's also a summer
internship program piece.
And they have hack-a-thons.
And it's a really great program.
And it's also a
little bit easier
in terms of the amount of
time that you have to put in.
It's still a good
amount of time.
But it's not a big
time commitment.
The second one, which is
a bigger time commitment,
is called TEALS.
It's a program that came out
of some Microsoft engineers
in Seattle who started going
into public schools in Seattle.
And now TEALS is
available probably
in 20 cities around the country.
And TEALS is, I think,
maybe in 20 or 30 schools.
And there, it's a
more intensive model.
You co-teach either an intro
CS class or an AP CS class
with a teacher.
So you are co-teaching
the class with a teacher.
Most of the time, you actually
have to go to the school
and be there for the hour or
the 45 minutes of the class.
They are experimenting
with videoing
into classes, which I
think, if it can work,
would be a great thing.
And I think where that
model likely is headed
is probably more
into the world of AP.
Because what's happening in
computer science education
is that it is now
really a growth thing.
And there's a lot of
schools picking it up.
And a lot of
teachers are starting
to learn how to teach intro.
But the AP stuff is
still pretty hard
and could benefit a lot from
having a real software engineer
there, either there
virtually or there in person,
to help students.
There's always that point
where a student gets stuck.
And just being able to unstick
the student is a big move.
And I think being a
real-world software engineer
makes it easier to do that
than if you're a teacher
and you're still kind of
dealing in the realm of theory,
as opposed to practice.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Right.
And I do like the
idea of teaching
alongside a real,
actual teacher.
Because they know how to keep
the classroom in good form.
Because that turns
out not to be trivial.
FRED WILSON: They do
classroom management.
They do all of the
homework assignments.
They do all the testing
and grading and deal
with the principal
and all that stuff.
And all the software
engineer has
to do is show up, co-teach
the class, go home.
There is a little bit of
upfront professional development
that has to be done just
so when you show up,
you actually kind of know
what the curriculum is
and you're familiar with it.
But it's not that much.
So those are the
two programs now.
I think there are going to
be more and more volunteer
opportunities.
Because-- you know, I
can't say too much--
but in the next
week, New York City
is going make a big announcement
about a massive expansion
of computer science.
And I don't want to get
out in front of that.
So I'll stop there.
But I think as part of
that expansion, I think,
there are going to be more
and more volunteer activities.
And the thing that
we've learned is
if we make the volunteer
activities more bite-sized--
and I heard that
Google has a 20-thing.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Right
FRED WILSON: So if
we said to somebody,
we'll take those 20 hours, and
you can give them to us an hour
at a time, or maybe
three hours six times,
or something like
that, and we make
it really easy for
people to do this,
more people would opt into it.
I think what we've learned is
asking a small number of people
to give us 100
hours is too much.
It'd better to ask 100
people to give us 20 hours.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Right, right.
FRED WILSON: And so I think
that's where we're going to go.
We've got more work to do.
And one of the things that
we probably need to do
is use technology.
You've got these
portals where you
show volunteer opportunities
to your workers here.
We need to figure out
how to put our volunteer
opportunities into your--
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Yeah.
I think some of
them are already.
But yeah, we should
definitely make
sure everything's represented.
FRED WILSON: Right.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so the mailing lists
are great, by the way,
just to plug those again.
And actually, before I
forget, I must say thank you
to Andrew Trenk, who's standing
down the back here, who's
been the energy behind a
lot of these initiatives
and also invited Fred along
and twisted his arm to come.
So thanks, Andrew, for
putting us all together.
FRED WILSON: Well, to
me-- my partner, Albert,
calls Google's New York
office team the gift
that Google gave New York.
And I think that a lot
of what we talked about
could not have happened without
Google making a huge commitment
to New York City.
Because you bring talented
people here to work here.
And some of them bleed
off into other companies.
But the opposite is also true.
People come here and work
for start-up companies
that maybe we're invested
in with the knowledge
that if that doesn't work out,
maybe they could come here.
CRAIG NEVILL MANNING:
That's right.
Right.
I think we've lowered
the risk a little bit
of coming to New York
and basing yourself
in New York as a tech person.
FRED WILSON: Yeah.
And I think, also,
it was a wake-up call
to the people who run the city.
They're like, well, they
own the whole-- I mean,
literally, this building is
like an embodiment of what
we're talking about here.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: It
was the funniest thing--
for the longest time, we tried
to get people to pay attention
to the fact that we're running
a tech organization in New York
City.
It wasn't until we'd made
a massive real estate
investment that people were
like, whoa, that's interesting.
FRED WILSON: Yeah.
Well, New York--
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Sad, but true.
FRED WILSON: New York
still is very much
driven by real estate.
Most of the great
fortunes that have
been made in New York over
the past 300 or 400 years
were made in real estate.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Right, right.
FRED WILSON: Because that
sort of was why that--
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
They're even funding
a great presidential campaign.
So there you go.
FRED WILSON: There you go.
I hadn't even
thought about that.
And that's absolutely true.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: So
you mentioned government.
So from your point of view,
how's the New York City
leadership helping, hindering?
What could they do differently?
What have they done that's
great in the last couple
of administrations?
FRED WILSON: Well, so I'm a
little bit of a libertarian.
And there's a part
of me which says
that the best thing
that government can do
is get out of the way.
And I think in large, as your
government has gotten out
of the way in the
sense that they haven't
made life more difficult
for tech companies
that want to work in New York.
And that's a good thing.
I also think that the Bloomberg
administration kind of really
woke up to what was going on in
New York with the tech sector
probably about halfway through
the second term in office.
And they did a great job
of amplifying all of that
and cheerleading it.
And cheerleading is a big deal,
particularly from City Hall
to be able to shine a
bright light on this.
That's helped a lot.
And that's carried over into
the de Blasio administration.
They have, more or less,
continued every investment
that the Bloomberg
administration was making
in promoting the tech
sector, promoting
tech-favorable policy,
and things like that.
I don't think it comes as
natural to the de Blasio
administration as it did to
the Bloomberg administration.
Mayor Bloomberg was
an entrepreneur.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Right, he founded
a company-- a tech company.
FRED WILSON: And
he kind of got it,
whereas I think the de
Blasio administration,
they very much want to
continue that stuff.
But I don't know that they
feel it in their bones
quite the same way.
So they maybe have
to work harder at it.
But I think the large
measure of the government
has been doing the right things.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Yeah, yeah.
Great.
So jumping back
to your business,
what are you excited about
in terms of technologies
both on the hardware side, the
software side, business models
that you think we're
maybe underestimating?
And I guess don't tell us about
the ones that are super secret
and that are still under wraps.
Butt what's out
therer that we should
be paying more attention to?
FRED WILSON: You know,
our firm isn't, by nature,
very secretive.
So if anybody reads my blog
or other writing that we do,
none of this would
be a surprise.
But we're quite interested
right now in the impact
that technology is
having on health care.
We're particularly
interested in the impact
that technology is
having on education.
We're particularly interested
in some new areas--
so those are some
verticals that we're
interested in-- some
new areas that we
have been making some
toehold investments in things
like Bitcoin and the
blockchain, drones.
And then one area where I
think we're sort of contrary--
although, Google is also
making a big investment here--
is in next generation broadband
internet infrastructure.
It sounds like kind of a crazy
thing for a venture capital
firm to be excited about.
But we think that the economics
of fiber and alternative
wireless infrastructure
is really quite good.
We've got this really cool
company that's not here in New
York in Portugal-- well,
we found them in Portugal--
that is building wireless mesh
networks for cities using,
basically, an 802.11p Wi-Fi
device that they put on bus
fleets.
And when the buses
drive around the city,
they're basically
meshing with each other
and provisioning
a wireless mesh--
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Wow.
FRED WILSON: --over the
entire city, which--
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
What is "p," by the way?
FRED WILSON: What?
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
I haven't heard of "p."
This is a different frequency
or a different protocol?
FRED WILSON: It's a protocol.
It's an 802.11 protocol
that's designed for mobile.
It's designed--
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: I see.
FRED WILSON: --for cars
and other moving vehicles.
It's very tolerant of--
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Right, handoffs, yeah.
FRED WILSON: --handoffs
and things like that.
But whether or not that
company will be successful,
it's an example of an
alternative approach
to doing wireless broadband.
That was very interesting to us.
So those are some of the things
that we're interested in.
And we're particularly
interested in the blockchain
for things that have
nothing to do with money.
We were talking with
a team here today
before we started who's
doing some interesting work
about saving logins
and passwords.
And the whole issue of privacy
and security and control
and whether I'm letting
Google have my passwords--
you could store all that
stuff on the blockchain.
Right?
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Right.
FRED WILSON: And
you're the only one
who has the keys to unlock it.
And there are some
usability issues around that
that we have to make
this technology easier
for the average consumer.
If I told my wife I was going
to store all of her logins
on the blockchain, she would
completely freak out on me.
But as an underlying
infrastructure for that,
it actually is quite good.
So that's another
area that we've
been poking around at a lot.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Right.
And to your point, it seems
like one of the challenges
is making this stuff
understandable to people
and presenting it in a way
that's more consumer-friendly.
FRED WILSON: Although, you
can do that with product.
You don't have to do that with--
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
No, no, no.
Right, exactly.
FRED WILSON: You don't
have to do that with words.
You could just--
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: But it
feels like the Bitcoin universe
is populated with
nerds like us, who
geek out on the nature of how
exactly the blockchain works.
FRED WILSON: Yeah, the Bitcoin
world needs a Steve Jobs.
It needs somebody who can see
the power of the technology
and make it just easy to use.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Right, right, right.
The good and bad news, it
feels like, about Bitcoin
and the blockchain is
it's not on the evening
news every evening
like it used to be.
FRED WILSON: Right
CRAIG NEVILL
MANNING: FRED WILSON:
And so maybe it's maturing
behind the scenes.
You, presumably,
know more about this.
It's becoming a more
mature technology.
FRED WILSON: Yeah.
But I do think that the jury
is still out on whether or not
it's going to be TCP/IP or it's
going to be token ring, right?
Is it going to be the thing
that becomes the standard
and everybody that gets
behind it, it opens up
all sorts of new possibilities?
Or is it going to be
something that ultimately
was a really great piece
of engineering that--
CRAIG NEVILL MANNING:
There's probably
a couple of IBM
people sobbing quietly
when you say "token ring."
FRED WILSON: Yeah,
that dates me, too.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Yeah.
FRED WILSON: A
lot of people have
no idea what token ring
is-- for good reason.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
And another investment
you briefly mentioned
was this drone idea,
which I don't know whether it's
a small idea or a big idea.
But maybe you can
describe what the--
FRED WILSON: Well, the
company that we invested
in is called DroneBase.
And it's really kind
of an obvious idea.
Instead of buying
a drone yourself,
just hire a drone pilot.
And they've made it
so expensive now.
For $399, you can go on
the web to dronebase.com.
You can pull up a Google map,
which basically their whole UI
is built on top of Google Maps.
Just map out where you
want the pilot to fly.
Hit Send.
And give them your credit card.
And about a day
or two later, you
get what is kind of like
a dropbox full of imagery.
And you can do whatever
you want with it.
And it sounds like, OK,
that's kind of interesting.
But how many applications
are there for that?
It turns out that there's a
lot of applications for that,
way more than I ever, ever, ever
thought that there would be.
And you tell people
about it, you
tell people who are in
real estate or construction
or run a manufacturing business
or run an agricultural business
or run a mine or they
run any kind of business
that has a physical
plant, and they're like,
oh, do you mean that I
could have somebody come
do a scan of my facade
to make sure that I'm
in compliance with local law 5?
And I'm like, I don't know.
I think so.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Yeah.
FRED WILSON: Boom,
another application.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Yeah.
Yeah, the physical world is fun.
I think we operate so much
in the virtual world and apps
on the internet and
on phones and so on.
Actually, the world
is becoming more
and more interesting
as this technology
impinges on physical reality.
FRED WILSON: Well, the
way I think about drones
is that drones are probably
the easiest form of robotics
for society to adopt,
because they fly,
as opposed to having to
walk or something like that.
So the number of
things that you need
to tell the drone to do
relative to a robot, I think,
are a lot easier.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Right.
FRED WILSON: And
so I think drones--
I guess I already said it--
but I think drones are maybe
the first big mainstream
application of robotics
to hit society.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Yeah.
That's an interesting point.
Apart from vacuum
cleaners, apart
from Roombas going
around on the floor.
And that's only two dimensions.
FRED WILSON: Right
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: So
clearly less interesting.
So is there anything else you'd
like to share with us, anything
we haven't covered that
you're excited about
or you're worried about or--?
FRED WILSON: Well, you know,
I'm a professional worrier.
So I worry about a lot of stuff.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: We've
only got another five minutes.
FRED WILSON: I would
say that I worry
that the world we live
in-- and I'm using "we"
maybe more to speak about
the venture capital industry,
or maybe entrepreneurs, but
I think it's probably also
true for people who
work in technology--
is a very optimistic world.
And we think that, oh, we
can solve that problem,
we can solve that problem,
not worry about that problem,
not worry about that problem.
But there are a lot of problems
that we face as a society--
everything from global
warming to terrorism and lots
of other things in between.
And I think that we, in
the technology world,
sometimes live in our
own little bubble,
where things are going
so great and there's
all these new technologies
coming along like drones,
like the blockchain,
other things that we
can get excited about.
And so I always worry
that something's
going to come out of left
field and catch us by surprise
and we're going to be
having to deal with it.
I mean, we've been through
that in New York with 9/11.
and other things
that have happened.
So we've lived through
that a little bit.
So I'm not like
a crazy optimist.
But I'm also not
pessimistic, either.
I'm kind of in the middle.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Maybe we
should, if you're up for it,
take some questions--
FRED WILSON: Yeah, I'd love to.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
--from the audience.
If you want to step
up to the microphone
if you've got any
questions-- yeah,
there's somebody over there.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
FRED WILSON: Yeah, my pleasure.
AUDIENCE: My question, I
haven't formulated it, maybe,
well enough.
So let me know if it's
completely unclear.
So in regards to computer
science education, if you said,
oh, it's very important
we teach kids Python,
or, it's very important we teach
kids JavaScript, you'd say,
that's kind of the wrong
level of granularity, right?
Like, it doesn't really matter
which language you teach,
you can always
pick up a new one.
And I guess I'm
curious how you'd
respond to the
assertion that maybe
coding itself is the wrong
level of granularity to teach
to kids.
I hear so much focus
around learning to code,
learning to code,
learning to code.
And is there a more
general set of skills
that we should be teaching
rather than coding itself?
FRED WILSON: Yeah.
Coding is, in my mind, a proxy
for the basic skill of telling
a machine what to do.
That's the thing that I want
everybody to know how to do.
Because I think
that we, as society,
are going to rely more and
more on machines to do things
that we want them to do.
And I think that the
basic thing-- like,
I know how to tell a
machine what to do.
I know how to write
a set of instructions
that a machine can process.
So [? Leanne, ?] who's
here in the audience,
I think-- who used to
teach computer science,
maybe some days still does
teach computer science--
told me that she likes to
start kids off with robots.
And I said, why do you do that?
And she said, well,
because it teaches them
very quickly that the
instructions that they gave
the machine were incorrect
when the robot smashes
into the wall.
And that's the
fundamental thing.
The fundamental
thing that I want
to make sure people understand
is the art and science
and techniques of instructing
machines what to do.
And unfortunately, that's not
as sexy as the word "coding."
So we use the word "coding."
But I think what we really
mean is whatever technique
is required for humans to
tell machines what to do,
is the thing I want
us to be teaching.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: We've
got somebody over here.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thanks for coming.
I have this question
regarding your views
about the Indian
start-up ecosystem.
Are you involved in it?
How do you see it going?
And do you see yourself
being involved in it?
FRED WILSON: Well,
so I don't know
a ton about the Indian
start-up ecosystem
because we don't
invest in India.
Our general rule
is if we can get
to a company within a six
or seven-hour plane ride,
we'll invest there.
So that basically
is a big circle
that you draw around New York.
And it kind of gets
to most of Canada
and most of Western Europe and
a little bit of Latin America
and all of the West Coast.
And that has to
do with just being
able to visit our
investments relatively
frequently without having
to put people on the ground
somewhere else.
But what I know is that, with
the exception of probably
China, India has
the most significant
entrepreneurial community.
And in some ways, I think
the Indian entrepreneurial
community is more
sustainable and more healthy
because it's a real economy.
In China, there's a lot
of government support
and protection for
their companies.
And that's not
the case in India.
So I think Indian entrepreneurs
are building great companies
in the same way
that entrepreneurs
build great companies
here in the States
or in Western Europe.
And there's a lot
of people in India
who have gone back to India
and brought back lessons
that they've learned
working in technology
companies in the States.
And that's also, I think,
generating a lot of the growing
vitality over there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
We have somebody here.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
the troubles with NJ Transit.
So I live in New Jersey,
as do many people here.
And between the devastation
of Hurricane Sandy and then
Hurricane Christie, I guess
in the opposite order,
we're facing a bit of a crisis
with the Hudson rail tunnels.
There are only two tubes.
They're damaged by Sandy.
And the ARC Tunnel
isn't happening.
So what do you think is the
role that tech companies here,
who are facing a potential
housing shortage when
those tunnels go in
for repair, what's
the role that you
think they can play
in helping solve this problem?
FRED WILSON: Well, I think
the solution is they've
got to build another tunnel.
Right?
I mean--
AUDIENCE: Right.
FRED WILSON: --that
is the solution.
And I think this is
a political problem.
It's not a technical problem.
And it's not a
financial problem.
There just isn't
the political will.
And part of the problem is that
the New York transit ecosystem
is not a centralized system.
There are lots of
different governing bodies,
and so on and so forth.
So I think what the large
employers in New York City--
and it's not just
the tech companies,
but certainly Google would be
an important one, along with JP
Morgan and Goldman Sachs and a
bunch of other big companies.
I think that the leaders
of those companies
need to go to the people who are
in control of these decisions
and demand it.
I think that decision that
Christie made probably
will go down in history as
one of the dumbest decisions
ever in the history of the
development of the New York
metropolitan area.
It's a huge problem.
And so I think the
employers in New York
need to get involved in creating
the political will to turn
that decision around.
And now we're set back,
whatever, five, seven years.
But we're not set back forever.
AUDIENCE: Can we have your help?
FRED WILSON: I'm
happy to be a voice.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
One last question.
AUDIENCE: Hey, there.
So Fred, thank you so much,
again, for coming here.
I'm a huge fan.
I've been lurking
on AVC forever.
So I love that this is my first
interaction with you instead
of actually posting a comment.
So a few things that you brought
up have me really interested
and I'd love to get
your thoughts on.
I think that it's
very important,
like you were saying, to get
children and schools really
interested about technology
and coding and seeing
that area of opportunity.
But I think there's another
way to maybe take that further.
And so I'd love to
get your thoughts
on what we can do to get
incubators, accelerators,
and those kinds of things into
some of these other boroughs
that you were talking about.
So Brooklyn
definitely has a few.
Queens is kind of
on the edge of that.
There's a few things out there.
But what we can do to drive
those ecosystems in the Bronx
and Staten Island, Long
Island, those kinds of things,
and get some of those
communities and those schools
that you were talking
about more interested
because they'll have role
models in the industry,
folks who are actually getting
these jobs and careers,
and also the inverse
of that question
in terms of
developing that talent
and supporting that talent
in some of these boroughs.
So that's kind of
a loaded one, but--
FRED WILSON: Yeah.
No, I really agree with you.
And there are a couple of models
out there that are interesting.
I think it's called the
Coalition for Queens
would be an interesting
model to look at.
What I think is
the right approach
is to go to organizations
who are already
on the ground in these boroughs
or in these communities
and find partners who
would be willing to do
a lot of the work of
staffing up a facility,
of doing the grassroots work
in the community to make people
aware of it and then bringing
in the technology partners,
whether it's a CSNYC
or a Flatiron School
or a General Assembly
or somebody else,
who has the know how
from the point of view
of bringing the curriculum
to the organization.
And there is also a
role in government.
There's a pretty
large organization
in the New York City government
around continuing education
and adult education and
retraining and things
like that.
So there are dollars that could
be leveraged there, as well.
So I think that there's no
question we need to do that.
And I think the
right approach is not
to try to spin up
a new organization
to do all this work,
but to try to figure out
how to get existing
organizations
and bring them to places
like the Coalition for Queens
or bring them to places like
General Assembly or Flatiron
School.
There are a lot of other coding
boot camps and accelerators
and incubators around.
Show them what's
possible that they could
build in their own communities.
It also might be interesting
to get the New York Public
Library interested in this.
Because they have
facilities all over.
The thing that a lot
of people don't realize
is the New York Library
system is really
two systems for a
bunch of reasons
that I don't have
time to go into.
But they have a
lot of facilities.
And a lot of people
in the community
go there to access the internet
and use computers and things
like that.
So they already have
some of the mindshare
in the community as a
place that they might
go to do something like that.
And, obviously, libraries
have to reinvent
what they're all about.
Because they're not going
to be about getting books.
So that would be another
idea in that vein.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Great.
Well, let's wrap it up.
Thank you again,
Fred, for coming.
If you're interested in
finding out more about CSNYC,
it's on the internet.
There's a website.
FRED WILSON: Yep, csnyc.org.
And pay attention next week.
As I said, I don't want
to preannounce anything.
But there's some exciting
stuff coming in the near term
that we've been working
on for a long time.
And so more to say
on that [INAUDIBLE].
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING:
Thank you for everything
you do in New York City.
And thank you for
coming along today.
[APPLAUSE]
FRED WILSON: Great.
CRAIG NEVILL-MANNING: Thank you.
That was excellent.
FRED WILSON: It was fun.
It was really good.